and then i'm not surprised you have time
crisis and metal slug in there because
yeah whenever we go to an arcade
together and that you have metal gear or
not
so metal slugs all right see you later
metal slug i've
always just been obsessed with other
[ __ ] uh that's metals like acts i
think i think
i think metal select is like the best
game overall
um if you don't know what metal slug is
it's a neo geo game that was really
popular in arcades and you can probably
still find it in a lot of arcades
um it's aged super [ __ ] well oh it
looks
like the sprite work on it for its time
was like insane yeah like and it looks
still what's insane and it's got like
some of the best [ __ ] sound effects
the
rocket launcher i love that [ __ ] yeah
yeah
i love those things yeah you always hear
those are like gaming com like dot exe
thing yeah
yeah yeah i [ __ ] love this grenade
like it's so good
like the gameplay is so goddamn clean in
that game yeah it doesn't overstay its
welcome it's like his six levels enjoy
them get the [ __ ] out yeah did you ever
enjoy contra
contra was really [ __ ] difficult i
mean it was that's yeah yeah i think the
the reason why
i don't like i think metal slug three is
like
probably one of the way too hard is that
like it goes from like you know level
one and two and metal slug three from
being you know a fairly challenging game
uh
people who played the game you could
easily breeze through it and then we got
the three
yeah and we were like [ __ ] this game
it's so hard
three like there is it is like you have
to play that game
every absurd amount because even if you
know where all the enemies are spawning
and where they're coming from
it's like it doesn't matter because
there's just so much [ __ ] it's
literally
yeah yeah it's complete [ __ ] i just
did it just to [ __ ] [ __ ] with you and
take your money
i just realized there should have been
another game on my three by three i'm
like
we're talking about this uh mega man x
yeah like i'm thinking i was thinking
like side scrollers i i completely
forgot how much i was obsessed with
science i was i was
tossing up between mega man x and mega
man 2 right yeah just
purely mega man x is just [ __ ] it's
it's like it still feels like anime
right it's got
it's got such an anime storyline yeah um
but
my god like the the gameplay in that is
clean as well
i forgot how much i loved hard games as
a kid yeah man i really [ __ ] now i was
like
hey because i'm like
man yeah i remember i completed contra
um
super contra at least on the snes uh
without that without the contra code
uh yeah without the controversy my
cousin i'm a hardcore gamer right yeah
i'm just like what
i remember completing mega man and that
was really easy what the [ __ ] happened
to me man
yeah because i was exactly the same like
i i haven't beaten contra without the
conjure code yeah
but like i i remember like how easy it
was for me to beat like mega man 2. i
could be in like an hour
and like you know a lot i think last
year the year before i was like i want
to stream some retro games oh i'll play
mega man 2. because i played that like
[ __ ] crazy yeah dude
i got like 30 minutes in i only beat
like two like [ __ ] robo boss i'm like
this game is [ __ ] impossible how did
i beat this as like a 10 year old you
should have patience man
yeah but no because yeah okay go for it
but like stuff with like contra like i
never played as a kid so when i play now
and like just [ __ ] kills you because
there's a lot of [ __ ]
right like yeah i'm just immediately
turned off from [ __ ] like that yeah no
this is just [ __ ]
it's it's it's weird because i i'm just
like this conversation has brought back
back so many memories about how how much
patience
i had as a kid because i remember
another game that was
uh people complain about being super
hard and super [ __ ] he was battle
toads
it was the level with the bikes right
yeah yeah yeah i i still remember the
level with the bikes and having to
complete that and completing battle toes
and i'm just like
man i remember i i think i just blanked
it out because there was just so many
hours of my life that were just
some [ __ ] level yeah and i just as a
kid you would just
mind numbingly just like [ __ ] learnt
it through um
through muscle memory right right and i
would not have the patience to do that
anymore
like if it was unless you value your
time you're like if there's something
like because battle told by the battle
toads let's be honest is [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah full of [ __ ] but i
[ __ ] love that game
yeah because you can't you can't play
that now and be like this is fantastic
it's like ninja gaiden for me as well
yeah
that game is just free yeah where it's
like i remember i almost beat that game
as a kid and i got to like i think like
the second to last level now
i can't even get past level one yeah and
i remember like i'm trying to think
about how the [ __ ]
did i beat mega man x on the [ __ ]
snazz controller
right my god i remember getting like
cramps and carpool tunnel from like the
like like tapping the jump button on the
wall like against some of the bosses
right
at least it's not as bad as a nest
controller dude that thing was [ __ ]
awful
in your hands yeah yeah yeah i i just
think for me metal slug is
the best age just a best overall
uh running gun i think i think it's one
of the one of the games that's like age
the best i feel like if you look at any
like
any indie game that comes out now that
is like a side scroller running gun it
just
it looks so inspired by metals oh yeah
my work is like identical
yeah it's it's like the blueprint of
like this is how you make a clean
running gun yeah it's you know metal
slug you know three is [ __ ]
um but like one two and x i mean x is
just kind of two
yeah like one two and x like i would
highly recommend getting x i think it's
on steam one and two are also on steam
you can get all of them on yeah go and
get it it's such a fun game
um it's just great when you play with
someone else right yeah yeah it's so
funny
it's so difficult as well it's just a
great game i mean it's clean